hi Matt here before we start our latest
episode we wanted to let you know that
we now have a think fast talk smart the
newsletter we'll provide bonus content
additional materials like articles and
videos previews of future topics and
behind the scenes information please
sign up at
stanford.io
TF TS newsletter again stanford.io slash
tfts newsletter also join us on
Instagram we started a new account think
fast talk smart follow us there just
like you follow us on LinkedIn think
back to a time where you were so
engrossed by a story you were hearing
that you lost track of time you were
just listening learning and experiencing
new things
this happened to me just yesterday as I
was listening in to David eagleman's new
podcast inner Cosmos with David Eagleman
now David is a friend a colleague and a
former guest on this podcast think fast
talk smart
and it reminded me of all the excellent
advice David gave
that discussed how our brains are
actually wired for story
so I invite you to sit back and listen
in as David and I discuss the
Neuroscience of Storytelling and I
invite you to listen to his new podcast
inner Cosmos
the professor in the very first
communication class I ever took started
by saying communication is very simple
you just need to get what's in your
brain into the brain of someone else
and while he was right the brains are
definitely involved there is nothing
simple about it
today we'll hear from a world-renowned
neuroscientist who will provide insights
into how our brains help us communicate
with each other
hello I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach
strategic communication at Stanford
Graduate School of Business welcome to
think fast talk smart the podcast
I am so thrilled to chat with David
Eagleman David is a neuroscientist and
an Adjunct professor and Psychiatry at
Stanford his research includes sensory
substitution time perception vision and
synesthesia
he is the author of eight books
including his latest live wired David
wrote and hosted the brain an
emmy-nominated television series on both
PBS and PBC and if that isn't enough he
has launched several Neuroscience
companies based on his research welcome
David thanks for being here great Matt
thanks it's a pleasure to be here great
let's get started
I'm sure Neuroscience has something to
say about how do we gain people's
attention and how do we sustain that
attention yeah I mean really at the
heart of this is storytelling there's a
sense in which storytelling over the
centuries has perfected structures to do
this to to make people feel like okay
there's something going on there's
something that needs to be solved
there's an unresolved chord here that
needs to be resolved we are suckers for
it it's you know there's a great book
um by Jonathan gotcha called the
storytelling animal and he uses the
analogy that if you remember at the end
of Star Wars when Luke has to try to get
this bomb into the Death Star and he
finds this little porthole and if you
can just drop the bomb right into that
little hole it blows up the whole death
star and essentially that's what
storytelling is to our brains it is the
porthole that completely can sway us can
make us feel like oh you know yeah make
us laugh because crying because
understand someone else's point of view
or at least push us in that direction so
that's you know that is really at the
heart of of what Neuroscience tells us
about how to you know how we communicate
and how we engage people so it's safe to
say our brains are wired to receive
stories is that what I'm hearing yeah
that's exactly right or a different way
of saying it is that stories are crafted
to plug into what matters to the brain I
want to jump into a point that you
mentioned about stories that stories
seize our attention and engage us are
there certain elements of Storytelling
that really capture the brains for
example is it is it being very Vivid or
using emotion are there things that
Neuroscience points to that really locks
our brain into story and communication
you know what's funny so I teach the
brain and literature at Stanford and one
of the things that has really I've been
chewing on a lot lately is that
everybody is very different on the
inside and some people just as one
example are very Vivid visualizers you
know if I say imagine an ant crawling on
a red and white tablecloth to a jar of
purple jelly some people see that like a
movie at the other end of the spectrum
some people just have a conceptual
understanding of it but there's no
picture there at all and and everywhere
in between and so it turns out that I
think there's no single answer to the
question you asked in terms of if a
thing is vivid for example
um what what I've been hypothesizing
lately and this is nothing but my own
idiotic hypothesis on this is that
writers like I don't know James Fenimore
Cooper or Thomas Hardy probably had
extremely good visualization and so they
assumed that everyone else their readers
would like that too whereas somebody
like Ernest Hemingway I assume had
terrible visualization and he assumed
that his readers would appreciate not
having all those details and so there's
no single answer to how Vivid to make
something because some people like Hardy
and Cooper and other people like
Hemingway
interesting so it seems to me that the
advice that would come from that is
twofold one uh remind yourself that your
world view is not the same of others and
second try to appeal to a variety of
different ways of seeing the world to
catch a bigger audience are those two
Fair takeaways yeah those are those are
very fair takeaways and you know I
should mention something because you
also asked about the emotional piece now
that's something we all have in common
now people you know people have
different levels of emotion if you're a
psychopath you really don't care about
someone's emotion other people are hyper
empathic and so on but that is actually
a big important part of dropping the
bomb into the Death Star is making sure
that you are finding ways to capture
people's emotions because fundamentally
people you know they don't necessarily
care about whatever the topic is you're
talking about whether that's physics or
gardening or genealogy or whatever what
they if you're speaking to a broad
audience you need to figure out what the
piece is
that connects to them that makes them
you know feel
something in particular that's the
important bit yes so you are echoing
what we've heard many times on this
podcast that really understanding your
audience and what's relevant to them is
critical to helping make for effective
communication and and you're layering on
that how understanding that relevance
and tying it to some emotion and some
story can really uh drive home what it
is you're trying to to do in terms of
connection and get your point across for
sure so I'd like to ask you you are
involved in so many fascinating research
projects and Ventures perhaps the most
intriguing is your effort to create new
senses can you tell us about this work
and then discuss how new senses might
impact our connection and communication
with others
I've always been really interested in
this idea of can we pass information in
the brain via unusual channels so I
mentioned you've got our eyes and our
ears our fingertips and our nose and
we're very used to this and we sort of
think these are fundamental but of
course this is just what we've inherited
from a long road of evolution but it
turns that you can push information in
the brain in other ways and so in my lab
we developed originally it was a vest
that was covered with vibratory Motors
we've now shrunk this down to a
wristband with a number of vibratory
Motors on it and we can pass very
detailed information in through patterns
of vibration on the skin so I spun this
out of my lab it's a company called
neosensory we're now on risks all over
the world I'll give you just one quick
example which is for people who are deaf
we capture sound on The Wristband and it
turns it into patterns vibration on the
skin and people who are deaf can come to
hear the world can come to understand
what's going on around them now we
actually have 70 different projects
going on where we're passing in new
senses for people either who who are
missing a sense or who just want
something extra like infrared vision or
picking up on the stock market or you
know uh whatever so anyway we've got all
these experiments but in answer to your
question about how that can impact our
communication and connection with others
one of the things that we're trying you
know we have tried uh is many smart
watches can measure all kinds of things
like your heart rate your heart rate
variability you'll get galvanic skin
response all these different things so
what we do is we pull it off the smart
watch we push that through the internet
and then to The Wristband so that you
are feeling let's say let's imagine
you're wearing the smart watch on one
hand and you're feeling you're wearing
The Wristband on the other hand
and you're feeling all these states of
your body that are normally invisible to
you like your galvanic skin response so
on okay but that's not the interesting
thing the interesting thing is your
spouse wears the watch and you wear The
Wristband so you're feeling her
physiology and and you can be because
it's through the internet you can be on
the other side of the globe and you
could you know call up and say hey honey
you seem like you're stressed out you're
having a bad day is everything okay that
kind of thing now I have no idea if this
is going to be good for marriages or bad
for marriages yeah I was just thinking
that yeah yeah it's probably a terrible
idea but I'm very interested in in all
the experiments that we and others will
be able to do with this in the near
future like what if you're wearing it at
work what if your colleagues you know
everyone's feeling each other's
physiology now again probably a terrible
idea but I think there's many
interesting things about connection and
communication to be tried here over the
coming years I find this David's so
fascinating and a use case for you to
consider is as all of us have become
much more familiar with virtual will
communication through a variety of
different tools wouldn't it be
fascinating if we could get some insight
into our audiences in the way you're
talking about haptically through through
these Sensations while we're in the
midst of communicating because all the
feedback that we get there are all these
tools that'll tell you talk time and how
intense your voice is but it distracts
you you have to look somewhere else you
have to be distracted from it and yet if
I had something on my wrist just
vibrating to give me that information in
real time I could make adjustments in a
non-distracted way yeah you know we've
actually done a version of that that
would only work for really really big
speakers but we have done this version
where we can scrape Twitter in real time
for any hashtag and then do an automated
sentiment analysis which is say are
people tweeting negative or positive
things about this with this hashtag and
on the Fly you can feel what thousands
of people are experiencing so this would
probably only work for like a president
or somebody who's giving a big live talk
but during the talk with a few seconds
delay anyway you could start feeling how
the whole Twitter sphere is responding
to you oh my goodness uh I I don't know
we have to be careful with that but yeah
fascinating fascinating
you know perhaps more than anyone I've
interviewed before you communicate in so
many different ways writing television
lectures and it to so many different
levels academic peers students the
general public would you be willing to
share a bit about your process for
creating targeted insightful
communication
hmm
yeah you know when I
sit in grad school
I tried to write my papers in in such a
way that the readers of these scientific
papers would have some reason to care
you know I tried to avoid passive voice
and use active verbs I chose beautiful
words when the situation called for it
and so on even though this was an
unusual choice for a science publication
and my mentors really worked to beat
that out of me they thought that it was
ridiculous that I was writing that way
but but I kept at it and I still write
my science papers in a way that I think
people can digest more easily the
science is exactly as rigorous but I try
to make it so that people care and they
get analogies and they understand what's
going on and so I think I would say
generally my writing has a lot in common
across all these different
audiences which is to say you can't
assume that anyone's going to care about
your particular Neuroscience study or
whatever unless you do the work to give
them a reason to care this highlights
you know for the reader this highlights
something about your life or or your
favorite actor or the way to raise your
kids or illuminate something about a
historical event that you thought you
understood but there's a new layer to it
or whatever but it can't just be hey I
ran this experiment here was the result
right um and this is equally true across
writing television and lectures uh it's
equally true across academics and and
communicating to the General Public well
I have I have read many of your books
and watched many of your lectures and
shows and and you you have an ability
not only to make things that for me seem
Out Of Reach reachable but you make them
interesting and and and I think it's
through what you're talking about
understanding your audience making it
relevant and connecting for sure I wanna
to hit on one issue that you'd mentioned
just briefly but you've demonstrated
today and that is the use of analogies
you use them a lot in fact today you
talked about Star Wars uh and I'm
curious to to learn more about it in
fact in your latest book the title lived
wired is is actually a an analogy too
I'm curious if you can shed any insight
not only to your use of analogies but is
there something in Neuroscience that
talks about the power of analogies you
know this okay great so this is
generally one one of the special ways in
which human brains function very
differently from computers so
a computer whatever you put into it that
just comes right back out it keeps one
file separate from another but with
human brains
you know Romeo can say Juliet is like
the sun and we understand that he means
she's bright and beautiful and
transforms Darkness to Daylight and so
on all the things that the sun does
brains human brains are particularly
good at understanding the structure of
things and then understanding ah okay
this is like this so it's a very
powerful way to get information in there
because it's taking a path that people
already understand and saying hey look
this is how the new thing works as well
you already understand this thing you
already understand what it is to load a
dishwasher or you know to see your
friend's face sort of drive to work or
what you know something people get and
then hey this thing is just like that
this very complicated physics concept
that you thought you would never
understand just think of it like this
bang and then that is the way to get
that bomb into the porthole nice and
nice way of coming back to that analogy
yeah I I learned actually from one of my
students how you can take analogies a
little too far but I totally agree that
they're very helpful in communication uh
we here in the US use a lot of sports
analogies to explain things especially
in business it's a slam dunk push it
across the goal line hit it out of the
park but if you don't know those Sports
you're in trouble and I had a student in
the middle of a speech he was giving
give an analogy to Cricket and you
literally could hear crickets in the
room because nobody knew how the sport
was played and he stopped and looked at
all of us and said that's how I feel
when you talk about American football
and it was very powerful so so
analogies I agree are wonderful but you
just have to make sure that everybody
has that pathway already that you're
talking about so thank you for that and
keep using the analogies they helped me
so much to learn what you're saying
before we end I'd like to ask you the
same three questions I ask everyone who
joins me on this podcast are you up for
that
yep let's do it all right question
number one if you were to capture the
best communication advice you ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would it
be
leverage storytelling and don't use
jargon ah nice so we've talked a fair
amount about storytelling can you can
you tell us a little bit more about the
problems with jargon yeah I mean this is
what you see in grad school all the time
is that you know a kid comes in they
feel intimidated by all their super
smart professors and that people are
sitting on their committee and and they
figure okay if I use all these jargony
words everyone's gonna think I'm so
smart and I'm so impressed but it it
loses an audience for every jargony word
you use you lose half them so so jargon
can obfuscate the meaning see I like
what I did there I used a big jargony
word it can get in the way of you really
understanding what's being said and
that's so true and and I guess the
challenge for many people is because we
use some of those jargony terms all the
time in what we do we have to remember
that not everybody else is part of that
lexicon and we have to back off from
using it for sure yeah and by the way
that is critical and you know I can tell
you how I solved that in my books and my
television which is yeah I'm always
crystal clear on who my audience is my
audience is me when I was much younger
and didn't know that word and didn't
know that piece of chart oh I like
that's who I'm talking to you yeah I'm
going to steal that that's great so so
instead of imagining necessarily who
this amorphous audience is just see
yourself uh at a different time in your
life I like it exactly and if that young
person would think oh my God that's the
coolest thing I've ever heard I had no
idea then then you're then you're there
you hit the bullseye great yeah um who
is a communicator that you admire and
why
you know for me it was it was Carl Sagan
um because he spoke so genuinely and
passionately about the things that he
loved and I grew up in the mountains of
New Mexico and aside from my parents I
didn't have a I didn't have a single
example of what
of what a science Communicator was like
of what Big Ideas could look like and
why they were beautiful and why they
weren't things to be intimidated by but
to be madly attracted to and so I would
say Carl Sagan single-handedly changed
my trajectory in life and I just I
regret that you know he passed away a
long time ago and I never met him but uh
he's he's the one that I admire in fact
I named my my son's middle name my name
Sagan oh cool what a tribute yes I I
think you and I are of similar vintage
and Carl Sagan certainly was an amazing
Communicator for sure yeah yeah and by
the way just on that vintage thing I'll
just mention I pulled up Cosmos on on
YouTube yeah you know the original
singing causes and had my kids watch it
and they loved it too because his stuff
doesn't age excellent that's a good idea
I need to get my kids watching some of
that too believe me it's much better
than what some of the other stuff you
watch
um what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe
you know this is a this is a very
specific tangential one but I I feel
like don't put words on slides unless
you really need them so somehow everyone
does these bullet bulleted lists on
PowerPoint and that's the worst thing
you could possibly do and the reason is
it's just very difficult for an audience
member to listen to you and try to read
what's written there at the same time so
it's very distracting so just don't use
words on slides I I am going to take
that sound bite that you just said and
I'm going to play it over and over again
I've been saying that for years but
having a renowned neuroscientist say
bullets kill don't kill your audience
with bullet points is phenomenal thank
you did you have other ingredients to
add
well yes I think I've already said that
but you know like don't don't try to
show off how smart you are by using big
words right and uh and and make it
matter to people through storytelling
right so it's about story it's about
using language that can connect to
people and it's about images and emotion
not just lists so so excellent that's
going to turn that recipe is going to
turn into a great dish for sure well
David thank you so much uh your insights
into Neuroscience into storytelling into
connecting with others is is fantastic
and Incredibly helpful and actionable
and I guess I should end uh by saying
May the force be with you since you used
Star Wars as a great analogy for us
I really appreciate being here
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast
produced by Stanford University's
Graduate School of Business for more
information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu or subscribe to our
show wherever you get your podcasts
[Music]